[Music]
gasps is a multi-talented performer who
can be seen in mashup airing the evening
of Tuesday December 4th on Comedy
Central and was also part of a team that
will be launching this site josh dot-com
in January please welcome our pal the
very talented Reggie Watts
thank you everybody thank you so much
this is a huge opportunity for me to
outline some brand new technology I've
been working with folks at Meijer Sound
MIT and a couple other institutions that
deal with sonic dispersion technology
all these speakers here are wired on 0.6
millisecond phase delay that will
increase the likelihood of you feeling
as though you're traveling through space
or time either one really you can pick
and for the studio audience is gonna be
amazing for you guys at home all the
viewers you may not get that effect but
you can go online at the site okay so
let's get started I'm gonna do this
little technology run and I hope that
you guys enjoy the immersive technology
of this performance all right there we
go
[Music]
- hello yeah yeah yeah I yeah okay yep
system - yeah system three yeah system
three is good we have cabling over here
running over to six okay all right
I guess we're gonna have yeah we got to
go to the contingency okay thanks a lot
how's your demo see ya okay sorry sorry
guys um I'm gonna try okay I guess we're
gonna do something like this okay
okay good luck
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]